[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
i'm very good thank jade how are you
welcome
now rumors have it yes you've been
training as a chef i have been yeah so
tonight you should be [ __ ] hot so the
pressure's on big fishes
hold on okay i might be the worst chef
that you've ever had balance up i think
okay
ross what's the menu ganache uh
no it's not g all right not sick noki
he's there no nokia main course and what
is it
it's the most expensive fish in the
market at the moment um
it's a fish oh from the wack
meet tonight's family brigade the
buntons
spicing up the kitchen tonight is emma
bunton drawn by boyfriend jade
former member of boy band damage who now
is a trainee chef in a gastropub
following in emma's footsteps is a
cousin ross a music student
the final member of the brigade is
jake's brother-in-law anton a
firefighter
with a restaurant full of hungry diners
the heat is definitely on
[Music]
so first thing i'm going to show you how
to do the nokia okay it's done with
fresh peas more beans
margin shallots and these wonderful
potato gnocchi nice hot pan
if it goes into cold pan it absorbs the
grease so they become really greasy
crusty on the outside nice and soft in
the center
shallots in nice hot pan touch of
salt half a teaspoon of olive oil
tablespoon of butter
okay the olive oil stops the butter from
burning
broad beans and our fresh peas they go
into the
boiling water see the color now
yeah nice and crispy right em any
questions
not yet come on you're used to pressure
jade you're used to pressure
anton you're definitely used to pressure
yeah and ross you're just a lazy student
that's right margaret in yeah quite wine
just a touch don't go crazy reduce white
wine down to syrup
that burns off his alcohol content a
couple tablespoons of cream in there
make sure that's nicely drained come on
keep up with me i am yeah
oh yeah please again now look at them
now see nice and
see how they've gone almost double in
size finish with a little bit butter
okay they come i've never seen nokia
like that yes
now we need crunch on the peas they're
fresh
so i don't want it too sticky over a
juice but just coating yeah and let's be
nice and generous with our gnocchi and
then finally finish it with
pecorino okay good ready yes yes yes
quick taste oh
gorgeous right now let's have jade
number on this side yeah ross and anton
over that side yes
yep good yes right are we ready
no that sounded pathetic are we ready
yeah sure right the bunsen brigade wakey
wakey on all the four covers table two
for knocking for seoul for crumble yes
yes sir excellent
let's go right emma yeah you set the
[ __ ] place on fire watch out
there you go turn you guys down a little
bit right jay don't put that butter in
there because if you haven't got the
color on the nokia
the butter will burn yes yeah okay good
no stop stop stop stop well they look
overcooked now
yeah they are completely overcooked keep
keep that down a bit more bubble just
reduce it a bit more yeah who the [ __ ]
bubba
is right okay that's much better jade
much better
yeah now you're getting the feel for it
now emma when's the last time you turned
the gas up and down at home
i don't i don't cook
he doesn't let me either though you know
when i try he gets really angry is he
that possible he gets angry with me and
he tells me to get out
so what do you do the washing up no i do
the wine i did
i put my heels on and i look because
four plate towels from there yeah on
there like that's gonna do that
yeah off you go clean your plates finish
it with pecorino
yeah and on the hot plate quick quick
quick let's go quickly
right here's janet street party
for the last four months janet street
porter has been on a mission to persuade
the public to eat british rose
veal they're going to go to the
slaughter house
we're going to slaughter them and then
we're going to eat them
last week she said goodbye to evil
calves david and elton
but her biggest test lies ahead
[Music]
preparations are underway for a very
special party up in yorkshire
i'm going to cook one of janet's field
cards in the f word restaurant next week
but today janet is going to serve the
other calf to 100 of her neighbors in
yorkshire
it's a big challenge for many of the
locals this will be the first time
they've tried veal
it's crucial it tastes sensational and
that's the job of the chef
tim clements there he is there he is
right that looks pretty heavy will it
rotate on the spit
i i hope so what if it's too heavy i
hope so well then we go move to plan b
what's plan b i'm not quite sure yet
janet wants as many people as possible
to try her veal
so she decided to spit-roast the entire
animal
a real challenge since veal is very lean
and spit roasts are normally reserved
for much fattier meats like pork
it's going to be a delicate operation so
how are you going to stop it drying out
we're going to keep marinating it
and we're off better be good otherwise
golden will be gloating
the meat is cooking and janet's keen to
convert the entire village to british
rose
veal so she wants everyone to join the
party will you come oh i can
oh right you can do it you can do the
blessing at the meal
will you do the flowers sorry to
interrupt your rehearsals
have you ever eaten feel no i feel like
i don't know have i eaten
i need a bit of entertainment we don't
want anything to have on guard to put
people off their meals
[Laughter]
janet's managed to persuade most of the
village into coming to her veal meal
that's only half the job she also needs
to make sure they love the meat they eat
after months of janet's care it's
crucial that david's cooked to
perfection
so the meat is constantly basting with
rosemary and olive oil as it slowly
cooks
wrapped in full to keep the juices in
someone have a taste
would you like to have a chicken no i
want to taste it along with everybody
else
if it's cooked now i think it'll be over
cooked i don't think it will be
we don't
let's hope she's made the right choice
to spit roast david or her months of
careful preparation will have gone to
waste
and i guess may be going home hungry
[Music]
four more way please yes jade yes
keep up the energy yeah come on yes
let's go pan on
good right right when they're brand
they're cooked they're black they're
what
yeah are you color blind um no chef
anton
yes yeah you know when things are
charcoal you're part of those yes
where's emerald get out come on let's go
look what he's doing
steve he's helping i'm taking over
taking over
antoine you're on fire put it down
you're gonna burn off the alcohol but
not set by yourself
there you go so what do you call nine
nine nine so how long have you choosing
silla
ten years ten years are you not married
yet no no he hasn't asked
are you waiting what are you waiting for
yeah
um have you changed your mind i just
think we're happy as well thank you
thank you very much service please table
eight yes
come on guys last two tables yes yes
very very good i thought he was gonna be
the [ __ ] surprise but hey well done
really well done
who are your favorites we'll find out
the results come through
okay well done yeah
the sauce was fantastic the the nokia
was really really tender it was
it was very tasty not as as pastry as
what i'm normally used to i would
definitely pay for it it was light
refreshing great textures really
enjoyable
it was really fresh it was great colors
gnocchi's was fantastic
right result for the starter yes yes and
how old
you did i hope they're spice fans right
you hope they're spiced
i thought personally you did a very good
job right nervous
okay so here's the thing the all saints
got 39 out of 50 for their starter
any better than that that puts you in
pole position jose
thank you so the number of customers
that are happy to pay
for their starters
[Applause]
coming up i'm on shift with the london
underground emergency response unit
what's the emergency cardiac arrest
and the people of north yorkshire
finally get to sink their teeth into
janet's field
bless dave and elton lord we pray their
lives were
short but bright and gay
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f-word now it's time
for the main course
doversol with a brown shrimp butter very
robust slightly sweet cooked simply on
the bone
is the best way flour
season coat the fish slightly dust off
any excess flour
pan olive oil
[Applause]
season olive oil
butter turn
into the oven 180 degrees 8-10 minutes
shrimp butter everything has to be ready
before you start because the butter
changes from brown to black in seconds
hot pan butter
cayenne pepper shrimps
capers and lightly season it
now the butter's just starting to catch
lemon
parsley sold out
nicely colored
[Music]
shrimp butter
[Music]
and over shrimp butter
done are we ready yes sure okay you know
how hot plate works so don't you
yeah yeah good that's because you are
going to run the hot plate i don't want
to cook with them
you can do this i don't [ __ ] care i'm
doing nothing
okay unless you give me orders okay i'm
your commie
you're in charge of the airport russian
are you ready get on your station chef
excellent
right two tables and four ramsey and
bunton
yes chef chef two tablespoons so you
just need two pans just two pans
oh my god this is hard cut the others as
well yep turn that over
turn it over how long are your sauce
ramsey frontal
coming right now it's all right yeah
just easy on the match yeah start that
one again let's match look at the mesh
on this table yeah
fountain smash is coming out beautiful
she's gonna get a gold star in a minute
how you doing remember watch those fish
yeah once you flip them
put them in the oven first part
next stop healthy food stand clear the
doors please
if there's a problem on london's busy
underground it's the job of the
emergency
response unit to deal with it
they tackle anything from derailments to
suicides are among the unsung heroes in
the aftermath
of the 7-7 bombings but this unit from
acton in west london are eating their
way to an early heart attack with greasy
breakfast
served by team member joe walsh in the
mornings we come in it's important that
we eat early because if we get a shell
we've got to go out
they'll have double eggs double bacon
double sausage
beans tomatoes mushrooms and a couple of
slices of fried
bread i'm here to sort out the eating
habits of london's underground emergency
response unit now this is where they
hang out whether on call but
i can tell there's trouble in there just
by the smell morning guys
joe how are you i'm already gone how are
you keeping him you're good to see you
aren't you well
yeah now it's 5 30 in the morning yes
and it stinks out there
and what's that there
you guys aren't eating that are you no
you are
am i [ __ ] eating that that's for sure
the elite
emergency response unit you're dealing
with all sorts
and you're eating [ __ ] you should be
[ __ ] ashamed of yourselves
i'm shocked by what these guys are
eating especially considering the
physical nature of their job
a few hours before the morning rush hour
i'm taken to a disused station to see
what these boys do for london's
commuters
could not just take the list lift
unfortunately it's not working
a faulty train pulls in and we get down
to work
the electricity on the line is turned
off and a short circuit device is stored
in case the current comes back on
how do we know the lecture's off uh the
tunnel lights are on so if the lights
turn off start shooting yourself
yeah start moving start moving easier
said than done when you're crammed under
a train with two
20 stone blokes i'm gonna take gold
under with you now then
anyone suffering from claustrophobic
down here i mean you're [ __ ] up
we're replacing a damaged wheel so the
first thing we need to do is to raise
the 25 ton carriage
using hydraulic jacks are we gonna yeah
we are going up
just trying to keep it square yeah off
you go boys down you go
get them back under their orders you
want to blow yeah no no i'm fine you're
fine
i'm just slightly concerned about the
smell of baked beans down there yeah who
is that joe
joe's on the other side joe can you turn
your ass the other way around please
it's right in the direction of my
[ __ ] face what i am amazed
is how physical this stuff is i mean
you're carrying some serious heavy gear
and that's not just your stomachs
perfect job
right pinning assembled good
golden you've seen what we do now [ __ ]
off our air station
how come we're under there i know why
you weren't under there
five years ago you could fit now you've
got no chance now it's time to show
these guys how eating more healthily
will help them lose weight and perform
more effectively
right i'm backing joe's calf to teach
you how to make the most amazing
breakfast
yes healthy straightforward delish and
quick
first peel the portobello mushrooms nice
thing about these
mushrooms they're low in calories olive
oil
salt and pepper on the baking trays
put the ricotta into a bowl they look
like janet's straightforward
grate your parmesan chop some oregano
mix together with a ricotta
spoon on the underside of the mushrooms
this is a very low fat cheese
and in terms of flavor it's
extraordinary
eight to ten minutes in there 220
degrees yeah 20 degrees
beautiful vine tomatoes really simple
yeah delicious
really healthy lots of vitamin c rye
bread is very high in fiber
and packed with vitamins and iron
better than the white sliced cardboard
they're used to that is a mushroom and a
half
i'm going to poach an egg a little
secret touch of
vinegar in the water and i just stir the
pan
so it starts to spin it round we'll drop
the egg in there
and it envelopes itself so the eggs
don't stick together and they cook
[Music]
nicely
[Music]
proper healthy breakfast i'll eat it
now it's very quiet yeah that's the
first minute i've been with you guys
no one said a [ __ ] thing it's great
[Laughter]
who's before eating a healthy breakfast
to start the day properly
definitely yeah we really enjoyed that
yeah it was fantastic
lovely crap get another phone randy if
you can
so they're going to please come here
four more on ramsay joshua
quickly we work well together i think we
do
you know i'm not gonna marry you yeah
chef listening
i'm pleased i'm pleased we're cooking
good idea chef thank you
why are you busting my nuts coming now
good send them yeah
thank you
[Music]
you've got four in if you can't have a
two on please ramsey two more in chef
yeah and then we're cooking two tables
of four chef or just one table
one table or two more sorry you've got
four in the other working sure yes
yes i need another two one sorry chef
i'm confused now so four plus two two
plus two twos on top of that are you
pissing about him
no i don't you just said that again he's
having a love no no no sorry it's
not your fault you know plus four not
twelve yeah just double check what a
double check chef that's all
adds on don't worry how's your match
how's your match yes
how are you doing randy coming right now
chef sauce ready
four double stop on the plate chef all
right
clean the plates [ __ ] you now done
okay well done oh
thank you right back to janet's spit
roast
tonight's the big night for janet after
four months of rearing her veil cars
david and elton she's invited a hundred
people from all over nidadale to try and
persuade them that british veal is a
fantastic tasting meat they should all
be eating regularly
the veal has been spit-roasted for eight
hours and is nearly ready for eating
have you had to look at it
looks good i was really worried about
spit roasting because i didn't think it
was right
but the way that he's done it i'm
cooking him really really slowly all
right
people have come from all over the
valley even the mayor's come for dinner
hi there hello hi
welcome to the upper dial get stuck in
have you had a look at it the weather's
great
let's hope the veal is too oh how's he
doing
all right looks good it's looking all
right isn't it all she needs now is a
bit of heavenly help
bless dave and elton lord we pray their
lives were
short but bright and gay
for those who have prepared this roast
bless father son and holy ghost
[Music]
at last the slow roast with rosemary and
olive oil marinade is finished
janet's farming skills have been put to
the test and now it's time to see if
it's all been worth it
it's chewy in that but it's still
gorgeous
[Music]
just how it should be
you've got a big potion it tastes lovely
spit roasting if you've got a really bad
idea fighting gonna be really dry
but it's not it's absolutely gorgeous
i'm up in the second
i've never had feel in my life i've seen
it on many menus and never picture
but i will now yeah it's terrific
it's a roaring success the lean and
tasty bill was cooked to perfection
and everyone's tucking into the feast
but just when you think it's safe
to relax i just want to have your
attention
for a minute but shut up for a minute
sorry
i want to thank you all so much for
coming tonight
everybody cares about these bloody
calves
the other day i went through the airport
a gatwick security man came up to me i
thought oh i'm gonna have one of those
embarrassing body searches do what
they had a brilliant life and what we
wanted to show
by rearing the calves here was that not
only is it wonderful me
but that it's a way of using animals
just go around and tell all your mates
british feel
is great
[Applause]
janet's veal meal has gone down a storm
and she's made some new friends
too the only thing we slipped up with
tonight because
don't tell me you're moaning about it no
no no no no we should have brought some
raffle prizes
if you're [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
janet seems to be on to a winner she's
got the people of nidadele eating
british for you
now it's time for the rest of us to give
it a go
[Music]
hello hello my darling
[Laughter]
trees are nice and bright and you know
good my veil mail was a triumph it's
going to be a hard act for you to be
serious
are they all obsessed with veal now in
north yorkshire
all of them loved it they're not just
scared of you in a way that they just
said
most of the people there had not eaten
veal before and they adored it did you
enjoy
being a farmer i really enjoy being a
farmer but then i take my hat off to
real farmers because they work every
hour god sends
for very little money and it's a tough
job you did
a [ __ ] good job it's maybe a more
caring sharing person
so it's a miracle i just want to give
you these what have you got for me
as a little present to say oh god gordon
it's so uncharacteristic
thank you nice names i really seriously
appreciate it yes
can't wait to cook elton i look forward
to seeing you next week lovely thank you
such feminine colors
just for you my darling
i've never tried oversold before it was
quite a life fish it was melt in your
mouth
i thought the nestle trap was very nice
bit different but then
the capers and the shrimps were a wee
bit salty
excellent nice combination of um the
shrimp and the capers
capers overwhelms the flavour a little
bit too much
but otherwise lovely
right results main course yes jade first
of all i was impressed with the way you
ran the pass yeah thank you
good job thank you i think you may be
quite cut out for this chef
right jose let's go give me the results
please thank you right
the number of guests that are happy to
pay for the main course is
30 out of 50. 38.50
that's not bad yes but it's not that
good
twelve not playing why the uh fish
overcooked fish overcooked
who's cooked on the bone so it should be
nice and moist and the potatoes are dry
who was it bloody hell jade
let's get 50 out of 50 for dessert yes
play down on the sections let's go
i know the old saint girls are winning
at the moment and they are my friends
but i want to beat them
i want to beat them i want to win it i'm
really excited i'm so competitive
that was amazing to be called chef by
mr gordon ramsay that doesn't happen any
day
coming up i find out what supermodel
erin o'connor likes to nibble on between
shoots i watch the quality of what i put
into my mouth
that's really important big difference
that's my message to the girls
and jon snow resorts to desperate
measures trying to put me off in the
recipe challenge thank god you're a
talented news reader
welcome back the f-word now time for the
recipe challenge and time to find out
whether jon snow can make a few
headlines of his own are you ready sir i
am ready
jordan yeah now good to see you what are
you making i am making uh
organic salmon phillips on a bed of
beans pine nuts and a few other
surprises right
that sounds a little bit like a jamie
oliver recipe it could be that that's
what its origins are
but it's been um organicized organicized
right i'm gonna do a really nice pan
seared fillet of salmon with really nice
summer broth how long do you sear it for
well do you know what i'm gonna leave it
a really intense color
and then just allow it to sort of rest
on the side you're just like a
politician you don't actually
answer the question how long are you
gonna serious before if i told you
i'm gonna see it for two minutes right
thank you very much needed to know i was
going to go for three
i got you two now john your potatoes are
burning oh [ __ ] oh gosh
so what was your mom's food like when
you were growing up it was classic
english food
really bread and butter pudding nice
roast beef yorkshire pud
toad in the hole oh lovely uh all the
sort of things which would make you very
fat
uh right my vegetables now first swim
off with no color so
just into a pan low heat
a touch of salt touch a pepper i've got
the
spuds done so they're really only for
dressing i've got some garlic stripped
ready for crushing but i haven't crushed
it
so i'm a little bit of a mess but i'm
getting there this dish is looking very
technical of yours johnny
it is of course very powerful yeah but i
know i should have forgotten something
absolutely critical and fundamental well
that would be fantastic if you have
i know i know now your father was a
clergyman and you're a news reader
so is your news desk a pulpit it's a
very interesting question
i don't know i don't know i mean no no
no because i'm not
sort of i'm not into morality or faith
or any of that
this is an interest you have strong
views don't you yeah interestingly
similar
sort of occupation yeah certainly a
performance isn't it yeah well
you don't get the clothes he had
fabulous clothes oh really
and the hat eight foot in a miter
they're extraordinary
foot just imagine a clunk bat and you
have your ties
outlandish yeah yes they have to be
abstract they must
say anything have you ever counted them
uh i know but i
i think they're always about 100 because
you know you be like you
i'm sure that you send your wooden
spoons to the auction for charity
well i i send my ties what's your
favorite tie what colors do you go for
bright colors i was told never to wear
bright colors on television
really so i wear bright colors on top of
it is it like bow tie equals small
i don't know i don't know if i've got a
problem or not i haven't noticed it if i
have but if i have
i accept it so
right vegetables that's all looking a
little overdone uh no it's not looking
well done we just sweat them off with no
color
a couple of tablespoons of white wine
reduce that down then add
vegetable stock so i've drained my
vegetables out there now because
vegetables are cooked added the
vegetable stock we'll reduce that down
and finish up the touch of creme fraiche
fresh basil and coriander then put my
peas and fresh broad beans in then
not looking what i intended now
i'm gonna finish the top of my salmon
with a really nice walnut pesto
garlic in john this is not going well
john you lived in uganda
yes i did yeah is it true you can sing
ugandan national anthem
yes that's amazing thank god you're a
talented news reader very nice yeah it
has a certain delicious craft
i'm just finishing my sauce with a touch
of creme fraiche looking a very much
nicer color than mine i'm slightly
nervous uh yeah i've got a very slight
element of self-doubt just the moment a
little rescue job has to go on here
we gotta clean that up somehow yeah
finishing my sauce
with fresh basil and fresh coriander oh
my god what i've done is i've got the
beans ready and they're
just on their moment i see an air of
panic over here
okay something's going on okay
hell right now someone's got to cook for
two minutes john's going off to change
his tie and then the blind taste will
come back and give john the bad news
[Music]
right i'm on a mission to get everyone
eating healthy food
this week i'm turning my attention to a
good looking group of people who've got
a bad reputation when it comes to diets
[Music]
a model's body is her livelihood so why
do so many of them eat so badly
i'm off to glean some words of wisdom
from supermodel erin o'connor
we should measure you sure let's have a
competition actually you're over since
we're actually six foot one
come on having been in the business for
ten years erin recently set up the model
sanctuary
a bolt hole which offers everything from
counselling to practical nutritional
advice
six two and a half six two and a half
very important
i've come to her agency to find out why
young models struggle so much with their
diet
how about the pressure in terms of their
eating we get a lot of models in and out
of the restaurants and they sort of come
in they dip in they dip out but they
don't
really eat they think they don't really
embrace the food i think they're scared
so maybe i'm a good
advocate for this because yes i do watch
what i eat but i watch the quality of
what i put into my mouth
right that's really important and that's
my message to the girls
erin's always been naturally thin and
two years ago she found herself becoming
the unwitting poster girl for size zero
despite improvements in the industry
erin's well aware young models are still
vulnerable
how bad's the problem now in terms of
their eating habits
they're young people they literally
they've left their parents for the first
time who've cooked their meals for them
from
that age and actually they go to a
foreign land they don't know where they
are they don't have the ingredients
accessible to them and they can't cook
it's a short sharp exciting career that
spans
if you're lucky 10 to 12 years three
years i represent a minority i've been
going for over 10 years now i mean i'm
practically a granny
how old are you now i'm 30. christ you
old bag i know
hi so isn't it you know working 30 old
bags
who cares how old are you gordon 31 are
you
so your big worry now is not so much the
pressure but these young girls can't
cook
um don't have the time to don't have the
time to cook i'm just trying
to encourage and make fun of the
benefits of eating well and positively
do you cook at home i do what's the last
thing you cooked last night i cooked
brown rice
salmon and add a bit of salad so it's
lovely and was the garlic in the brown
rice i did just
do
aaron knows that to keep looking good
you have to eat healthily
but there are still a few models at our
agency who don't
i'm going to be meeting georgina
georgina is is a perfect example
of a lot of young models she is going to
have a fast-paced life and she's got to
know
and she's got to see the benefits of
looking at number one
[Music]
in london with 18 year old model
georgina toms now
she got spotty outside woolworths in
manchester a few years ago and she's
been freshly modelling now for the last
two years
she's a lot of crap i eat biscuits
lots of biscuits chocolate a lot pizza
and crap stuff
probably student kind of diet i suppose
alcohol and
all that good stuff for you
the average model's career lasts for
just three years
georgina may look great now but if she
carries on like this her shelf life
could be shorter than a packet of her
favorite biscuits
so i'm here to show how easy it is to
cook and eat a balanced healthy diet
great chance hi georgina hi how are you
all right
traveling wise are you traveling a lot
yeah in the past months i've been to
hamburg milan and madrid
how do you eat when you're on the fly
like this
um whatever's available what's up
available but that's not what you have
for lunch is it
no that's just snacks i can eat half a
packet of biscuits a day if i want to
half a packet no chance yeah seriously
yeah
i like biscuits it's like my downfall
are you confident in the kitchen
um i can do it but i might like
burn myself accidentally no that's not
gonna happen get changed we'll go to the
kitchen
and we'll cook something vibrant healthy
and incredibly
easy okay okay i'm going to prove to
georgina that healthy food can be every
bit as tasty as a beloved biscuits and
chocolate
pancake tuna with really nice couscous
and some roasted vegetables
chop the veg peppers courgettes
leeks and red onions okay do we need
lots of onions i don't like them you
don't like onion once they're roasted
in olive oil you'll be surprised mixed
together with olive oil
salt and pepper
[Music]
to serve alongside i'm using couscous
which is low in fat
and high in fiber add a dash of olive
oil and pour over the hot stock
cover with clin film and leave it for 15
to 20 minutes to make a really quick
vinaigrette
just two thirds extra virgin olive oil a
little bit of salt a little bit of
pepper a little touch of white wine
vinegar
fresh lemon juice and zest now for the
tuna
crush some coriander seeds with some
seasoning this is like
probably manual labor in it labor of
love it'll be worth it
get some willy in there season the tuna
and coat with olive oil and the crushed
coriander
heat a frying pan then add the olive oil
and sear the tuna
take out and leave the rest for a few
minutes take our vinaigrette
all nice lemony now with the couscous i
keep on shaking the bowl
i've got to move it all now it's all
stuck at the bottom that's why we give
it a good shake now so it doesn't become
stolen
[Music]
add fresh coriander lemon zest and juice
and a couple of spoons of the
vinaigrette
vegetables out the oven a nice spoon of
couscous
on there our vegetables yup and see the
grains of the tuna
yeah slice with that on top
finally that is a very quick easy
healthy
tuna okay right off we go yep back to
the studio
that smells amazing yeah excellent
i'm not keen on onions but try it
it just actually tastes nice yeah good
has it given you a source of inspiration
to go and cook yeah i know i can do it
now
and it's kind of easy once you showed
how to do it i'm going to eat all of
this just so you know
let's do something different yeah you
run the hotplate this time
you're absolutely right no [ __ ] way
get on your sections let's go
right time for dessert gooseberry and
elderflower crumble within their ice
cream
[Music]
gooseberry and elderflower crumble a
great summer version of a winter classic
the gooseberries just top and tell them
and sugar orange zest
caramelized as the caramel starts to
turn
that's what i want there that really
nice golden color
gooseberries in it
elderflower cordial and the other flour
helps to give that syrup a really nice
flavor
orange juice
[Applause]
slide off the heat and look the whole
thing starts to break down to this
delicious
pulp crumble topping flour
sugar butter and all we do now is just
rub the butter through
[Music]
hazelnuts crush your nuts
mix
[Music]
get your gooseberry and elderflower two
thirds
in and then with your crumble mix
nice and lightly place it on top
into the oven 220 eight to ten minutes
look at that beautiful ice cream
gooseberry outer flour crumble with
vanilla ice cream
done watch the camera please don't flick
it
it's [ __ ] piping hot caramel and
it'll go straight through your skin yeah
okay yeah yes [ __ ] gordon can you check
that does that seem yeah
it looks like you've pasted it into one
big ball ross
honestly look at the state of that
[ __ ] thing it's like all clumped
together
but that's nice jade thank you yeah good
i'm straight in the oven have you always
wanted to be a chef
i think when i was finished with music
yeah i
just immediately found a passion for
cooking but why did you decide to leave
music so young
um i've i've been in the music business
for 16 years
and i just kind of got bored of it and
and did you make any money with damage
yeah but
a little bit of money you got enough
money to buy mopeds and that was about
it
seriously so [ __ ] all basically oh cool
yeah
okay guys go go go go go go your plates
out and fill your ice cream on there
yeah i'm jay
i think your pan is [ __ ] no careful
careful don't forget
so you wet it every time you go in there
oh really yeah yeah how would you get a
nice perfect ball
service please
[Music]
chase what's the advantage you've got
out of an old woman no seriously
give me some tips i'm standing here with
a knife look at that face look look it
looks
fine now lovely blonde hair blue eyes
and a big [ __ ] knife
yeah that perfect's beautiful when the
ice cream's on straight away just send
them huh
let's go guys good they're ready to go
guys perfect off you go
jade well done well done
right jose what was the score then
coming up
will jon snow hit the headlines by
beating me in the recipe challenge i
don't like it that close but who was it
too
come on and the bunton brigade find out
if they're coming back to cook for final
service next week the number of diners
that are happy to pay for the dessert is
[Applause]
right welcome back to the f-word now
time for the results the recipe
challenge now yours looks
absolutely gorgeous yes yeah mine is
dissolved and yours looks like something
out of the channel 4 staff canteen
cruel and joyful man yeah get back to me
i've got it jose come back with the
right result yes good luck
good luck hello hi
absolutely delicious very distinctive
lemon flavor
it's very lemony isn't it very summery
dish isn't it
it's like digging oh that is lovely it's
good
there's a lot more flavors you say
coconuts
i could almost prefer it and slightly
less cooked
i like the one with potatoes
the salmon's just cooked nicer tastes
tastes better
i prefer the one without potatoes
[Music]
it's lighter and it's got better flavors
the one with potatoes
it's just the fact that the salmon is
just cooked to perfection
i prefer the one without potatoes
all the flavors really complement each
other the sauce keeps the salmon a lot
more moist
can i just say your [ __ ] mushrooms
are still in the oven
i know i screwed up hi student you know
then i had to make a mistake i left the
mushrooms in the oven
failure what role were they going to
play they were only a frill
and it's better without the frills okay
damn so if you lose you're going to
blame your mushrooms
right jose what was the score then three
two
what i don't like it that close but who
was it two
come on gordon yes three
two i think two is pretty good actually
but if i'd had the mushrooms i'd have
had the three
so oh just imagine had those mushrooms
gone out
i'd have got the three now jonathan just
before we go a little present for you to
remember me by
yes god and we're on the news wow now
[ __ ] off out of my kitchen
this will be worn on epic occasions
has anyone worn [ __ ] on television
people have won [ __ ] all on television
but
[ __ ] i don't think they're bubbles i'm
wearing this with very great pride
i think this is the best chastisement
i've ever received
i was a bit disappointed by the dish i
was really looking forward to the elder
flower in the crumble but i can't really
taste that yeah i think it's great it's
uh it's nice and sweet it caught me by
surprise i wasn't expecting hazelnuts um
i've never had that in a crumble before
how are you um
how was your a dessert bit burnt
a little bit burnt well it's certainly
um yeah caramelised i can clearly
identify that you you didn't like that
it was a little bit overcooked
excellent how was yours i loved it thank
god for that man at the table although
elderflowers are weak well listen i'm so
sorry you found the hell of a week but
more importantly i'm happy and enjoy
you're so sorry about yours being
slightly overcooked
right jose results please let's go yes
let's go let's get this game the moment
of truth
right so the number of diners that are
happy to pay for the dessert
is
36 out of 50.
damn why they couldn't really taste the
elder flower
are they all cold what else and they
didn't like the texture
it's a [ __ ] crumble it's a crumble
soft and crumbly oh no
from me personally i thought you did a
[ __ ] good job it's not good enough to
come back next week but
you should feel proud of yourself it's
been an absolute pleasure having you in
the kitchen
thank you yes now jade one final piece
of advice yes
please don't open the restaurant
opposite me i'm starting to get nervous
yes